on saura ce qu'on appelle les plans de
transport les impacts précis à la SNCF à
la RATP en fin de journée sans doute
pour mardi tout sera évidemment
communiquer en détail ça sera je vais
pas le l'indication précise ça sera une
journée difficile voire très difficile
dans les transports publics pour ce qui
m'intéresse qui me concerne le plus
directement le cacher aux Français donc
je le redis comme je l'avais dit 19
janvier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
peuvent s'organiser pour faire du
télétravail pour reporter un déplacement
c'est mieux de le faire ainsi il y aura
des perturbations fortes c'est clair le
degré de mobilisation je ne connais pas
aujourd'hui il y a des déclarations de
grève on les connaîtrait en fin de
journée